my name is Igor lutetium karate Prime
Minister Montenegro I very much believe
that innovation helps expand frontiers
of economic prosperity in the region of
eastern europe southeast europe where my
country belongs to all Central Asia and
I believe we have to do more in focusing
on innovation focusing the science
proximal education because that's the
only way to improve the economic
well-being and what I believe we should
do we should rely more upon public
private partnership aid schemes as it is
evident that governments could not do
everything and government should create
environments the government should
cooperate with the private sector and
government should promote the need for
innovation and
all those schemes that improve the
overall performance and I believe that
bridge that I come from is probably one
of the regions which has the biggest
economic potential and we have to use it
the way to use it is to rely upon the
skills and talents of our people and the
only thing we could do about that is to
invest in education and and and
stimulate innovation
is that okay